saturday this was actually a lot of fun
a packed lifeguard arena saturday
evening down in downtown henderson the
second annual freedom face-off charity
hockey game between local veterans and
first responders the teams play for the
heart field cup that is a trophy in
honor of late metro police officer
charleston hartfield who lost his life
in the one october shooting money raised
goes to veteran and first responder
charities in the valley i had the
pleasure of emceeing that event for the
second year in a row packed place more
than 700 maybe up to a thousand people
inside lifeguarding to watch the game
there you see the hartfield family there
they were sitting right at center ice uh
veterans won the game i think it was
seven to two was the final score
but it was really obviously about the
the greater good and the greater reason
for having the game in the first place
but uh it was intense
there was almost a fight or two
i think a bottle was thrown on the ice
at one point so it was a it was a wild
scene